and finally new role liberals have to
stop trying to win over Trump voters
with facts you're wasting your breath
and you're going to need it because the
air is not getting in
[Applause]
[Music]
just look at these hundred days
headlines no regrets Trump voters
unanimous the myth of this disillusioned
Trump voter even voters and liberal
Massachusetts are sticking with Trump
numskulls find a whole new level of numb
all right I made that last one up at the
toilet the point is Trump supporters
aren't changing their minds because the
problem isn't in the mind it's lower its
emotional stop clinging to the false
hope that if we just share this Facebook
story about the time that he tried to
have lunch with Frederick Douglass or
high-five Stevie Wonder or criticized
Obama for playing golf and now he plays
Marco you're preaching to the yoga
studio the jury is in he looks and acts
like a man who's been painting his face
with orange LED for 40 years his people
know they don't care he could have Anne
Frank's skeleton in his closet they'd
all vote for him again the question is
why why do they stick with him I think
it's because of a gut feeling that the
world has changed and they don't like it
and Trump is going to change it back to
the way it was when a real American
good flip around looking for a radio
station and not have to hear mariachi
music
[Applause]
the media keeps saying that the thing
that got Trump elected was economic
anxiety but it's really more change
anxiety I ain't no racist but why does
America need to have a black Santa Claus
does everybody have to do everything No
I think I speak for most liberals when I
say I'm okay with blacks and I don't
think it's going to make the little
drummer boy start cutting himself but to
Trump voters making Santa black is
unthinkable it would be like making
Jesus middle-eastern
this is why building that stupid wall is
still the key issue for them because it
represents keeping out not just
immigrants but everything that's new and
different and scary and unfamiliar you
guys probably agree with me that it's
kind of cool that you can write a
musical in hip-hop now like Hamilton and
I'm okay with seeing this guy playing
this guy but Trump voters don't want to
see that the founding fathers had been
funkified
[Applause]
[Music]
ain't broad we're supposed to be in the
Great White Way and while we're at it
does camera one a baseball have to be
Mexican now Lopez Hernandez Martinez
Fernandez Ramirez when did the Yankees
become the parking lot at Home Depot and
what is it with men kissing on the kiss
cam and then I mentioned Bruce Jenner
has tits now see that guy my new
character that guy got used to having
the whole country always bend over
backwards to make him feel comfortable
Trump voters they're not exactly racists
they just think everyone who's not white
is doing it to show off you know in the
50s if you were an actor named chouet
elegio for you placated conservative
snowflakes and bent over backwards for
them and changed your name to chip Egan
chip Egan starring in that new movie
with Danny Huston Lily Nile Mark Allen
ginger McGraw and Gayle Smith
if you ask a trump voter what exactly it
means to get their country back or make
it great again they can't tell you
specifically but they know the Hollywood
Squares was never supposed to be remade
on TV and looked like this
[Laughter]
if we just would build that wall black
people would stay in their cubicles
Coleman never came out of his cubicle or
the closet